the covet vaccine rolls out despite
media predictions it wouldn't happen by
year's end
the electoral college votes for joe
biden and attorney general william barr
steps down i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
second first you may have noticed it's
been pretty chaotic out there this year
it's gonna be chaotic
into the future because we are spending
money that we simply do not have which
means that you can expect at some point
there will be tax increases or there
will be inflation
here is the bottom line you're going to
want to diversify at least a little bit
into precious metals and this is where
my friends at birch gold
come in how about putting some real
silver in your loved ones stocking this
year that's right because right now
through december 21st for every 5 000
bucks you spend with birch gold group on
physical gold or silver or
investing in your precious metals ira
birch gold will send you bonus silver
which is a great deal it's the countdown
to inauguration day
it's a great time to pull some of the
earnings out of the stock market
solidify those savings
through diversification and god forbid
the democrats were to win those senate
seats in georgia things could get real
dicey for your stock portfolio really
quickly
here's what you need to do text ben to
47 47 47 when you speak to your birch
gold representative let them know you
want the free silver with your purchase
even if you're investing in a precious
metals ira you still get that physical
silver delivered directly
to your door i've been working with the
folks at birch gold for years they're
people that i trust they're people i
think you should trust as well
call them up ask them all your questions
get all your answers and then look to
invest with birch gold tech benz 47 47
47 get a free information kit on
diversifying into gold from my friends
over at birch gold a plus rating with
the better business bureau countless
five star reviews again text ben
to 47 47 47 to open that precious metals
ira and get that free silver before
december 21st alrighty so we begin
this morning with a fascinating piece
over at the
columbia journalism review this piece
was not meant to be a rip on cnn
but it is in fact a rip on cnn because
it just goes to show
how the sausage is made when it comes to
the media media
very often are not following the news
they are creating the news or they've
decided to craft a narrative and they
are going to
fit the news into the narrative and this
becomes perfectly obvious
in this piece from the public editor of
the columbia journalism review
ariana pakeri it's called cnn public
editor what comes after trump and kovid
it seems like a good moment with the
ends of the trump administration and
global pandemic insight to ponder what
is next for cnn
after years of long chaotic days news
producers on the brink of burnout or
well past it
are certain to welcome a time of
relative calm as long as they are able
to retain their jobs
warner media announced a new round of
layoffs this fall at a recent company
town hall its chief executive jason
killar was asked if cnn was at risk as
some have speculated
kellard didn't explicitly say no a
reporter noted his deadline but appeared
bullish on the cable news network
highlighting
its recent ratings success inside the
network according to informal
conversations with several staffers in
the weeks since the election there is
pride that cnn ended the month
of november on top in the coveted 25 to
54 year old demographic both in prime
time
and in total day audiences there's a
belief the network may benefit from the
fact that fox news fans are depressed
and msnbc has not yet figured out how to
position itself in a changed news cycle
but
says the columbia journalism review like
every other news network it may struggle
in 2021 cnn must figure out how to cover
a biden administration that isn't
defined by conflict
having a president in trump was well
versed in reality tv and whose main aim
was to outrage and troll his political
opponents has been a boon for ratings
likewise trump may have broken the
grading curve think about the potential
controversy if joe biden had been the
first to nominate a recent general to
lead the pentagon
and so this columbia journalism review
article is all about how cnn is now
looking for a narrative and this
is the dirty little secret about how the
media do their business
it is about ratings in the end it is
largely about ratings they're not
following the most important news
they're not following the most vital
news
they're not telling you the truth about
the news they're not providing you a
well-balanced view of the news
they are there to drive a narrative and
if that narrative sells
well that's what they're looking for and
so right now cnn is looking for a new
narrative now we know
that this is what mainstream
establishment legacy media outlets do
we know that the new york times for
example in the aftermath of the failed
attempt by robert mueller's team to go
get donald trump that the new york times
dean maquette held an editorial meeting
with all of staff
and said we are going to shift resources
into covering the racism narrative and
then magically voila within the next
year
every single story turned into a racism
story got the george floyd protests we
got the protests in the streets we got
the 1619 project and all of this
right we know that the new york times
officially
stated that they were following a
narrative now usually newsrooms are
called newsrooms because they cover the
news
not because they're narrative rooms but
let's be real about this
legacy media establishment media they're
not there to cover the news they are
there to make the news
so what exactly will cnn be looking to
push over the next few years
according to the columbia journalism
review the chatter within the network is
that there's an appetite for a dramatic
news storyline to replace trump
most likely to be propagated internal
discussions have suggested through
punditry instead of more expensive and
risky reporting
it could pit the moderate biden
administration in opposition to those on
the extremes of his party
or depending on republican behavior the
narrative may dissect biden's prediction
that he was best suited to forge
bipartisanship
the network will also seek a biden
whisperer a journalist impeccably
connected as the new york times's maggie
haberman has been with trump who can
offer access and micro scoops on the new
administration
the well-intentioned journalist at cnn
says the columbia journalism review
may still have to fight to do anything
other than conflict written segments
that seek drama
to juice ratings and this is the point
okay cnn is going to look for whatever
is the juiciest
and not only whatever is the juiciest
but whatever is most calibrated to
please their leftist audience notice the
narratives
that colombia journalism review is
suggesting one is joe biden is too
moderate and the other is joe biden is
too moderate right
those are the two narratives they are
suggesting one is that he's too moderate
for the radical wing of his
party and the other is he's too moderate
compared to these terrible awful evil no
good very bad republicans
and it is this drive from the media to
create narrative
that has driven the backlash against the
media it is this drive
by the media to craft narrative that
means that we no longer trust
the media and it's why there's so much
doubt over our institutions i've been
saying this for the past week
to use the metaphor again if the media
are the glasses through which we view
the world and if it turns out the lens
is cracked
it makes it very difficult to discern
what is beyond the lenses
and as we see from our media they are a
cracked pair of glasses
right they are shading the world in a
particular direction and so you don't
know what to trust
and this is why there's so much endemic
mistrust in all of our institutions up
to and including
our elections okay well last night the
electoral college did vote to elect joe
biden that was perfectly
predictable obviously the state votes
had been certified in states ranging
from
michigan to pennsylvania to georgia
there's still as we'll get to
an ongoing legal case in georgia but
with the vote of the electoral college
that means that joe biden is officially
the president-elect at least until he is
ratified january 6
by the congress of the united states
there's a procedure for that here is
what that looked like last night when
the electoral college which again you
have
basically people meeting in every state
they voted to elect
joe biden president which again is in
accordance with the votes in those
states as currently certified by those
states
i will now nice to announce the tally of
the vote for the office of president of
the united states
for joseph r biden of delaware a
democrat
eyes 55 knows zero
okay that was the state of california
that was announced in california put
biden over the top last night
and the media were just beside
themselves they were beside themselves
at the magic
of this moment and it was very clear
obviously who they were rooting for
right you saw people like cnn's david
chalian saying it's time to celebrate
democracy now i don't remember this sort
of talk after the 2016 election when
donald trump won
right then it was the electoral college
is very bad we need to stop talking
about the electoral college let's do
popular vote kind of stuff but now it's
a celebration of democracy because of
course
this is narrative it is not fact-driven
that's an opinion here's cnn's reporter
he's a journalist
david chalian it is sort of a day
to step back and celebrate democracy but
it is also a day
that has responsibility attached to it
our responsibility
to show all the viewers to show the
country and the world
this process unfold uh while donald
trump and his allies want to suggest
falsely without
any any realm of fact
that the election was rigged or stolen
or some way uh
not what it is so much journalism
happening right there it's a magical day
for democracy
in a way that 2016 was not a magical day
this was just it was it was a great day
because cnn has a narrative to drive
now the republicans in many of these
states have put up what they call
alternative slates of electors those
electors have not been certified by the
state legislature so they don't actually
really mean much the only way they would
mean something is if there were a legal
challenge that would be elevated to the
supreme court which would overturn
the electoral slates that have been
created in these various states or it
got to congress and then there was some
way
that congress voted to overrule those
state electors and then they would put
in these replacement electors
that isn't going to happen but that is
what has been happening
on the ground as far as what republicans
are doing now all of this tied into the
joe biden narrative so joe biden decided
that he was going to do a victory speech
last night
joe biden didn't have to do a victory
speech last night he did a victory
speech the night of the election
and in fact he's going to get to do
another victory speech presumably on
inauguration day
when he's inaugurated in january so why
exactly did he bother to do this
victory speech again the reason is out
of spite right i mean that's the only
reason that he needs to do this the
process worked as the process is
supposed to work people brought their
legal challenges
the states rejected the legal challenges
the supreme court rejected several legal
challenges
and and then the electoral college voted
okay but he he felt the necessity to go
out there
and do a speech about how he was going
to be a president for all americans
while
basically crapping on trump and crapping
on trump supporters which
is a strategy i don't think it's a very
good strategy but again it ties into the
broader democratic narrative which is
that
donald trump is an enemy of democracy
and joe biden is a friend to democracy
as we'll see there are some questions to
be brought about just how much of a
friend to
democracy and freedom of the press joe
biden is and meanwhile the media
continue to craft that narrative in just
one second first
let us talk about the fact that
everybody loves waffles okay waffles are
just
they're they're great great food they're
amazing okay and
if you want the best way i have ever
seen to make waffles let me tell you
about the presto stuffler
stuffed waffle maker this thing is just
unbelievable so over the weekend
i actually broke out the presto stuffler
stuffed waffle maker
and i put the batter in the way that
works you put the batter in and then you
put what you want for the stuffing in
the center you put some more batter in
you flip it and then you just let it
cook
oh my lord the waffles that came out of
this thing
are just unbelievable my kids were in
love with it they were helping me put it
together
and then my wife got into it we ended up
making waffles that had like
peanut butter cups that you put in the
center they melted in the center of the
waffle it's just
unbelievably ungodly good stuff waffles
for break
they're not just for breakfast they're
for everything and you can use the
presto stuffler stuffed waffle maker to
cook belgian style waffles for pretty
much everything you can do sweet
like we did you can do savory you can
put like chicken meat fish eggs
cheese veggies it's also deli it's all
delicious stuff inside the stuffler
made waffle it's just it's easy to use
it's really simple you can use any
batter you put it in
you flip it it's good to go it's really
really easy to use
let me tell you it makes a great
hanukkah or christmas gift go to
stufflord.com click the buy now and then
the add to cart button
enter promo code ben to get ten percent
off this gonna be part of our sunday
routines from now on go to stuffler.com
click that buy now and then add the add
to hit the add to cart button
enter promo code ben get 10 off again
stuffler.com promo code ben
after you add it to the cart amazing
product go check it out right now
stuffler.com promo code ben
alrighty so joe biden decides that he is
going to do
a victory speech now again there's no
necessity for the victory speech
right i mean he thinks that this thing
was over election night
it's now officially been voted on in the
electoral college which means officially
he's president-elect
okay and that means that he's going to
be able to do a big inauguration but
that's not what this is about what this
is about is again driving the narrative
forward
the narrative is always and forever that
joe biden is a friend to democracy
democrats are friends to democracy while
republicans who have outstanding
questions
or who are upset about the election
those people are enemies of democracy
but don't worry joe biden stands for all
of you
all of you so here was joe biden last
night
a member of the of the electoral college
representing the certified winner cast
their
votes for presidential and vice
president united states
in an act just as old as our nation
itself
and once again the american america the
rule of law
our constitution and the will of the
people prevailed
our democracy pushed tested threatened
proved to be resilient true and strong
okay so again this is part of the
broader narrative which is that trump
filing lawsuits in a variety of states
is somehow a threat to democracy no
actually you know it's not a threat to
democracy
working within the actual system of the
democracy in order to challenge election
results
whether you bring the evidence and you
overturn the results or whether you
don't bring the evidence and you don't
the process worked it was supposed to
work and the fact that trump challenged
the election
you know he had every right to do that i
think some of the things he was saying
were not accurate i think that many of
the claims that he has made are not
backed by sufficient evidence to
actually show their truth
but the idea that democracy was ever
truly under threat here is
pretty ridiculous on its face and yet
that is the narrative that's going to be
driven because again for democrats the
rule is when they win democracy worked
when they lose democracy did not work so
when donald trump
won in 2016 democracy did not work in
fact i have
right in front of me four years ago a
bunch
of different famous people on the left
talking about how democracy had not
worked
because john because donald trump had
won december 12 2016 john podesta of the
clinton campaign
he literally said the bipartisan
elector's letter raises very grave
issues
involving whether electors have a solemn
responsibility under the constitution to
have their questions addressed so he was
saying the electors right
a bipartisan slate of electors back in
2016 said hillary clinton won the
popular vote maybe we should vote for
hillary clinton
in the electoral college and john
podesta the clinton campaign was like
those those questions deserve to have
answers
joy reid tweeted out an opinion piece
from the washington post titled
the constitution lets the electoral
college choose the winner they should
choose clinton
chris hayes over on msnbc i love
democracy over there now
he tweeted out on december 6th 2016. fun
fact
states decide how to apportion their
electors they could give them all to say
whichever candidate won the majority of
counties
jonathan weissman of the new york times
said the framers left electors free to
choose they should exercise choice by
leading the election
as the people decided it right so
there's a whole push by the left in 2016
to overturn the results of the electoral
college and to push against how the
electoral college worked but now we are
being told of course
that anybody who challenged the results
of election in legal processes
inside courts across the nation that all
of this was anti-democratic
nope that is perfectly within the
boundaries of how all of this
was supposed to work and in fact you
know who knows this is
joe biden and the reason that we know
that joe biden knows this is because if
you go all the way back to 2016
there was an attempt actually on january
6 2017
rather that was the date on which
congress had to ratify the electoral
college when donald trump was elected
and you know who had to preside over the
ratification was vice president
then vice president joe biden democratic
lawmakers
tried to overturn the results of the
electoral college in early january of
2017. here's the new york times
reporting january 6 2017
one by one the democratic lawmakers
stepped up to the microphone on friday
holding on to their letters and an
impossible dream
denying the presidency to donald j trump
two weeks before his inauguration and
one by one
vice president joseph r biden presiding
over a joint session of congress to
validate the electoral college results
turn back their challenges with a stoic
message pounding his gavel without
hesitation
it is over biden said at one point as
republicans rose to their feet to cheer
so biden knows better than anybody else
that there are a bunch of democrats who
are perfectly willing to overturn the
results of the 2016 election
representative barbara lee of california
for example she got up and said mr
president
i object because people are horrified
the members quote spoke of voter
suppression
of russian interference and of the
bracing fear consuming many americans
repeatedly biden asked if anyone could
produce an objection that was joined by
a senator
he said in that case and then when no
one could he said in that case the
objection cannot be entertained
as the exercise neared its end
representative maxine waters democrat of
california said i do not wish to debate
i wish to ask is there one u.s senator
who will join me biden reached for his
gavel
as biden read at the final numbers there
were conspicuous demonstrations against
trump erupting among visitors to the
gallery
one woman shouted i rise to defend our
democracy we reject this electoral vote
i rise to defend free and fair elections
a man cried in a moment
donald trump as commander-in-chief is a
threat to american democracy
a couple people were arrested at the u.s
capitol and biden knows that right so
was that a threat to democracy
not really the process worked as it was
supposed to work was this a threat to
democracy
not really the process worked as it was
supposed to work
and biden continued with this sort of
quasi-vindictive victory speech was
mostly designed to again suggest the
narrative which is he is super
pro-democracy dude
loves democracy but people who oppose
joe biden
don't love democracy even if they accept
the results of the electoral college
because that's how the process works
we'll get to that in just one second
first
let us talk about the fact that it's a
busy time at your front door that means
there are a lot of people ringing that
doorbell a lot of people on your
doorstep and you want to make sure you
know what is happening
at your home in fact when we moved my
wife's first comment to me was let's get
ring devices on the door we need to make
sure
we know what's going on at the house
plus i have three children under seven
and they have decided that they will now
mobilize against me they actually
perform
tactical operations against me they call
themselves the army of the children i'm
not kidding
my six-year-old daughter calls herself
the general which she is
frankly because uh her lieutenant is a
little bit battle-hardened the
four-year-old in any case
she uh she has declared that they will
mobilize against me i have to keep track
of all three of these children on a
regular basis there's only one of me
there are three of them and they can
usually outflank me but not
when i have not when i have my ring
devices and you need your ring devices
too
with ring you can see and speak to
whoever is at your door from anywhere
with video doorbells keep an eye on
every corner of your house with easy to
install indoor and outdoor cams help
protect your whole home with ring alarm
a powerful affordable ho-home security
system you can easily install yourself
and for a limited time go to ring.com
ben for special holiday offers again
that's ring.com
forward slash ben for special holiday
offers ring.com
offers and to get started
alrighty so joe biden continued with his
victory speech
and no necessity for this he did this
because it's all about narrative driving
so here he was saying i won by the same
margin that trump did
yes and i'm sure that you will receive
the exact same media backlash that
donald trump did in the aftermath of his
win in 2016. here was joe biden
the vice president-elect harris and i
earned
306 electoral votes
while exceeding the 270 electoral votes
needed to secure victory
306 electoral votes is the same number
of electoral votes
that donald trump and vice president
pence
received when they won in 2016. excuse
me
at the time president trump called his
elect the electoral college tally a
landslide
by his own standards these numbers
represented
a clear victory then and i respectfully
suggest
they do so now and then biden continued
by talking about the legal processes
that were in place
he had to clear his throat a fair bit
which had people speculating on his
health somewhere in the background
kamala harris was getting very very
eager in any case here was joe biden
talking about the legal processes in
america
when questions are raised about the
legitimacy of any election
those questions are resolved through the
legal processes
and that's precisely what happened here
the trump campaign part
brought dozens and dozens and dozens of
legal challenges to test the result
they were heard again and again and each
of the time they were heard they're
found to be without merit um so
here is the thing you can't have it both
ways if the legal process
worked then it wasn't the threat to
democracy was it i mean seriously he's
saying the legal prop we have a process
the process worked and then earlier he
was saying that it was a tremendous
threat to democracy from trump and team
trump
now again this is all just part of the
bull crap lie that you're going to be
sold
over the next several years which is
that if you oppose anything that joe
biden does it's because you're an enemy
you're an enemy of the majority you're
an enemy of democracy or a radical
okay that is that is part of the broader
narrative push that is going to be made
right here okay now how do you know that
that
so much of this is narrative because
we've been told of course that joe biden
for example is a great friend to
liberties a friend of democracy a friend
of the press right donald trump is one
of the natives the media drove for years
is that donald trump was a threat to the
press the washington post put up a
slogan on their front page
democracy dies in darkness it was just
for trump that's the only reason they
put it up there they decided that
democracy dies in darkness because
the freedom of the press was a dire
threat under
sure donald trump didn't jail
journalists sure he didn't surveil them
in the same way that
obama did in fact he didn't even try to
propagandize to them in even the same
way that obama did i mean ben rhodes
overtly said in an interview
that he was lying to an echo chamber of
idiot foreign policy journalists about
the iran deal and they just
lapped it up certainly trump never
received that sort of credulous media
attention
from the establishment media but we were
told that the trump was a radical threat
to the press
okay so far joe biden has not answered a
single difficult question
in the entire campaign in in the
post-election period he's not answered a
single difficult question
so yesterday he finishes his little
victory speech and peter ducey from fox
news
immediately pipes up and says question
when did you know that hunter biden was
under was under prosecutorial threat
when did you know that he was under
investigation okay that's a real
question
it's a question that he has been
avoiding its question that dr joel biden
i've been
reliably informed by lots and lots of
people that dr joe biden is in fact the
greatest she's not just a doctor she's
the greatest doctor like i it basically
goes dr jonas salk
dr joel biden dr anthony faucet that's
it that's how it goes in terms of
in any case dr joel biden basically
slammed the front door on reporters who
were asking questions about hunter so
peter ducey whose job it is to be a
reporter
he asked a reporter question and joe
biden got mad because this is what joe
biden does because it turns out that joe
biden
has the same sort of politician
dictatorial tendencies as most other
politicians in washington dc
he is all in favor of freedom so long as
that freedom expresses itself in support
for him
if if it cuts the other way then not so
much so here was here was the end i mean
honestly he does this whole thing about
how democracy
has been vindicated and how the process
worked and then peter ducey does a
journalisty thing
and joe biden thinks that journalist
jobs are to kiss his ass this is what he
thinks
so this exchange is pretty incredible
may god protect our troops
and all those who stand watch over our
democracy
thank you
thanks for the con the congratulations
appreciate it thank you
okay so what peter ducey is shouting
when did you know that your son hunter
biden was being investigated mr
president-elect
and biden turns back to the press just
like he doesn't he could just ignore it
and walk off stage he can't right
instead he turns back he says thanks for
the congratulations it is not
the job of the press to congratulate you
that is not the job of the media that is
not j but you could
listen biden could be forgiven for
thinking that he could
i mean he spent his entire career in the
warm caresses of the media ever since
barack obama decided to pluck him from
obscurity and make him
his vice president so why wouldn't he
think that it's the job of the press to
kiss his ass
i mean so far that's what they've been
doing they did it the entire time during
the election cycle and that is what
that's the narrative you can prepare for
from now on is joe biden's just too good
he's just too freedom loving he's just
too democratic
he's just too unifying that's the big
problem that's the reason he can't get
anything done
is because there are just too many
people who are mean to joe biden
particularly on the right they're just
mean to joe biden and if it weren't for
that
joe biden would be able to get things
done he'd be more popular probably
that is the way the media are going to
treat this because everything is the
narrative and the narrative is
everything
in just a second we'll get to the
media's narrative about covid because it
turns out that was completely wrong and
then they wonder why people don't trust
them when it comes to their coveted
coverage now
it's because you've been wrong on pretty
much everything on that particular score
we'll get to that in just
one second first global pandemics civil
unrest politicians infringing on your
inalienable right to defend yourself
now more than ever emotions are running
very high in our country as a result
more and more law-abiding americans are
making a rational choice and they're
purchasing firearms to protect
themselves and their families
you may be one of the millions of people
who've recently purchased a gun for
self-defense if you're a gun owner
you have to be aware of self-defense
laws where you live it's really not
responsible to own a firearm and not
know the legal ramifications of using it
you need proper education
you need industry-leading training to
ensure your skills are sharp when faced
with danger plus
the uscca has purchased an insurance
policy that provides the association and
its members with self-defense liability
insurance
you need the u.s concealed carry
association get started today by texting
gun to 87-222 you'll receive the
complete concealed carry and family
defense guide for free
in this guide you'll learn how to detect
attackers before they see you how to
survive a mass shooting seven firearms
drills that could save your life and
much much more it's a 164 page guide
loaded with valuable information in
addition
if you text today you'll be entered to
win a thousand bucks to put toward a gun
of your choice that you can use to
protect your family
text gun to 87 222 right now again
that's the word gun gun to 87 222 right
now to get started
you'll be entered to win a thousand
bucks to put toward a gun of your choice
and you'll get the
free 164-page guide the complete
concealed carry and family defense guide
for free when you join up with the uscca
text gun to 87
222 right now to get started okay so
meanwhile
in actual good news for the country the
vaccine
that trump said was going to be
developed by the end of the year has not
only been developed it has now
gone out it is being received across the
country one of the first people to
receive it was a new york nurse
named sandra lindsay who said that she
received the vaccine and she feels
i great great it didn't feel any
different
from receiving my annual influenza
vaccine
i am very proud to be a healthcare
worker
and i'm also very proud to be in this
position
to promote public confidence in the
safety of the vaccine
i encourage everyone to take the vaccine
okay so this thing went out and went out
by the millions of doses apparently 2.9
million doses went out the front door
just a little trip down memory lane when
it comes to the crafting of narrative so
you'll remember that over and over and
over during the campaign trump said by
the end of the year we're going to have
a vaccine
and the media just kept throwing cold
water on it it was impossible it was
never going to happen
so you're misha alcindor you know trump
ripped on her to white house press
conference and the entire media
infrastructure came through
oh my god she's such a great journalist
incredible journalist here's what she
tweeted
may 15th 2020. president trump just now
at the white house on a coronavirus
vaccine we're looking to get it by the
end of the year if we can
moving on at record record record note
experts and officials say it is likely
faster than what is possible
okay then there is jonathan steven
greenhouse over at the new york times
what this is august 27 2020 what three
question marks trump boasts inanely
we'll produce a vaccine by the end of
the year and maybe even sooner
is trump suggesting he'll pressure the
fda into approving a covered vaccine in
and reporter for the new york times
politifact fact checked on april 23
2020 okay they fact checked because
trump said
that uh the us is very close to vaccine
they fact-checked it
is the u.s very close to a vaccine for
the coronavirus as president trump said
during tonight's coronavirus briefing
public health experts say it could take
a year and a half to roll out
excellent fact-checking politifact you
are not biased in any way
charlotte climber the uh the lgbt
activist
put out a tweet from the debates in
which trump said during the debates we
will have a vaccine by the end of the
year this is only in october it's
october 22nd when it was becoming pretty
clear that we were very close to a
vaccine
trump tweeted out we'll have a vaccine
by the end of the year new year's eve
and then it was a thing from um
from riker on on star trek
from unsolved mysteries saying this is
fiction this is fiction
this was all made up aaron rupar from
vox.com
he tweeted out a clip of donald trump
saying that the vaccine would be
available in a couple of weeks this is
november 2nd
2020 and rupaul then tweeted that's the
surest indication yet that we're not
close
hmm excellent journalism there by aaron
rupar objective
journalist from box.com very explainy
over at vox.com again sometimes
jessica hoosman tweeted go ahead and
flag this tweet trump tweeted on may
14th good numbers coming out of states
that are opening
america is getting its life back vaccine
work is looking very promising before
end of year
jessica hussman tweeted go ahead and
flag this sweet for and we do not have
that vaccine by the end of the year
how about we flag your tweet tim o'brien
lib commentator said no one in trump's
own government at least those leading
operation warp speed whom i interviewed
believes a safe properly tested
coronavirus vaccine will be ready by the
end of the year
amazingly irresponsible for trump to be
touting this in the midst of this crisis
august 27th
2020 and then of course kyle griffin
from msnbc
whose twitter account as a low-level
producer over at msnbc for i believe
lawrence o'donnell his twitter account
can
because he apparently has like the
emails of everybody in the echo chamber
if he tweets something it becomes like a
national story
he tweeted out may 15 2020 a fact check
from nbc
coronavirus vaccine could come this year
trump says experts say he needs a
miracle
to be right oh look a miracle
or alternatively you guys were lying the
whole time
because bottom line is that you wanted
it not to be true many of you were
rooting for it not to be true
you weren't willing to hold off on it
you weren't willing to just say okay
well
you know it's possible that this could
be the case instead you jumped to
it's in november right the day before
the election people were tweeting it's
impossible a vaccine will be available
by the end of the year the very next
week
the very next week which by the way is
not a coincidence you started to see
drug companies come out of the woodwork
and say oh yeah by the way
all of our studies have been going
really really well if that news had come
two weeks earlier maybe that affects the
election dr marty mccary from johns
hopkins university
he had serious doubts i had him on the
show he had serious doubts as to whether
that was not held up by the drug
companies for electoral purposes
there are a couple of stories that were
really held up before the election
that could have made a difference in the
election they really could have this is
why when people say it's rigged
they're as rigged as in like people
formally changed votes or the
voting machines were hacked and then
there was rigged as in the conditions of
the election
were not free and fair on a broader
level in that all the information that
you should have known was not made
available
to you if we had known a week before the
election if the american people had
known a week before the election
that the vaccine was going to be ready
and good to go by the end of the year
and that in fact companies like pfizer
had the vaccine ready and good to go
like we know for a fact by the way
that pfizer already had the numbers and
the fda administrators inside the fda
made them go back to the drawing board
and add a few more people onto their
study even though they already had
enough results to announce
we also know the hunter biden story was
out there and we know that was not
confirmed by the doj and the media not
only refused to report on it they
actively attempted to suppress the
information
on the hunter biden story we know all
that stuff would that have made a
difference in the election it certainly
wouldn't hurt trump
that is for sure it certainly wouldn't
hurt trump in any case the vaccine
is being rolled out that is a triumph by
the trump administration
anthony fauci the greatest of all
doctors like the actual
apparently he's not just a doctor he's
like the best doctor in all the
in all the land dr falchi he said that
there will be hurt immunity
by the end of june 2021 which by the way
also gives the light of bill gates's
bizarre comment that we wouldn't be
getting back to normal until 2022.
harry was talking about her immunity i
had been saying by my calculation
sometime by the end of march the
beginning of april that the normal
healthy man and woman in the street
who has no underlying conditions would
likely get it
at the end of the day the real bottom
line is
when do you get the majority the
overwhelming majority of the population
vaccinated so you can get that umbrella
of herd immunity
and i believe if we're efficient about
it and we convince people to get
vaccinated
we can accomplish that by the end of the
second
quarter of 2021 namely by the end of the
uh late spring early summer and by the
way point of fact
you know in the media which has now
shifted its narrative so we have to
convince all of these unbelievers to get
the vaccine
that shifted immediately on the election
like onodime
andrew cuomo went from we have to have
our own state commission
to determine whether the vaccine is safe
to give us the vaccine like right now
and i'm going to be out here and i'm
going to be telling all of you that you
need to get the vaccine
it's like dude five seconds ago you were
saying that you couldn't get the vaccine
because it was developed under the trump
administration
the good news is the vast majority of
americans say they would receive the
vaccine
40 say they will take it as soon as it's
available 44 say they would wait a bit
before getting it this seems to be age
striated as by the way it should be
if you're elderly or you're vulnerable
you should be looking in the vaccine
like give me that sucker right now
and if you are young and you are healthy
you might be saying i'm going to wait a
little while because
who cares if i get it i'm probably going
to be fine right by the actual
statistics if i'm 20 and i get it
then my chances of death are exceedingly
low if however i'm 65 and i have a
preexisting heart condition give me the
vaccine
right this very instant only 15 percent
of americans according to a new poll
say they would refuse the vaccine
entirely in the new survey that was
conducted by ipsos in partnership with
abc news
more than eight in ten americans say of
course they will receive it
among those who've been most closely hit
by the pandemic 45
said that they would receive the vaccine
right now among americans who have not
contracted the virus or don't know
somebody who has only 30
say they would be willing to be not
inoculated immediately
only seven percent of americans over the
age of 65 say will they will never be
vaccinated that number rises to 20
among those between 18 to 29. 93
of elderly americans say they are
willing to receive the vaccine
more saying they will get it right away
57 rather than further down the line 36
80 of us adults under 30 are willing to
get it but they're more likely to say
that they would
wait rather than getting it right away
that's actually good news because again
we're going to be tranching this thing
out so if you're young you are going to
be waiting for it so the fact that
you're willing to wait for it is
probably not a bad thing so all of that
is very good news with regard to the
vaccines meanwhile
new york is talking about doing a full
shutdown okay despite
data suggesting that the shutdowns
probably are not going to do anything
the reason i say probably is because
there are contact tracing
studies in new york right now that show
that the vast majority
of coveted spread is happening in
household transmission here is mayor
bill de blasio the most garbage mayor
in america and man is that a close
battle between a bunch of democratic
mayors ranging from eric garcetti to ted
wheeler
in portland to lori lightfoot in chicago
to keisha lance bottoms in atlanta
and now you have de blasio still has to
top that list here he was saying they
may have to do a full
city lockdown again there's the
potential of having to do
a full pause a full shutdown in the
coming weeks
because we can't let this kind of
momentum go i mean think about it for a
moment this city was the epicenter we
fought back we became one of the safest
places in the country we opened our
schools when most major cities didn't
we've kept our schools safe but now
we're seeing the kind
of level of infection with the
coronavirus we haven't seen since may
and we have got to stop that momentum or
else
our hospital system will be threatened
okay so
quick note he's talking about shutting
down all of the restaurants like all of
them
well it turns out that restaurants and
bars account for less than two percent
of new coveted cases in new york
two percent that's what new york
governor andrew cuomo said
he said private gatherings account for
the vast majority of new statewide cases
according to newsweek
less than two percent are coming from
bars and restaurants according to the
data
74 percent of new cases have come from
private social gatherings
he said in many ways you can understand
what happened you close buyers you close
restaurants you close theaters you close
stadiums you close math
mass gatherings where do people go they
go home well no that's actually
not totally the case what's actually how
this was always true
okay the virus continued to spike in new
york even after most of the shutdown
happened
the reason being people went home and
they stayed home with people for more
than 15 minutes
of course the number one vector of
transmission is people being at home
but they're talking about shutting down
everything in new york
my friend dave rubin had a good sweet
you want everything to reopen tell
everybody in congress
tell all of your mayors tell all of your
state legislatures none of them get a
salary until things are open
so they can be just like all the people
that are shutting down and then we can
talk about
what should stay open and what should
not stay open what's an essential
service and what is not an essential
service already in just a second
we are going to get to the news that uh
william barr the attorney general of the
united states
is stepping down as of next week first
let us talk about the best pillow on the
market okay so there are some great
pillows on the market but the best
best one that i know is my pillow okay
this thing is so comfortable
we got one and then it turns out that my
wife was like stealing it from me at
night
and so we just got another one and you
should because
the premium my pillow is regularly 69.98
for
but now you can get it for only 29. 98
to 40 savings
that's the premium queen size my pillow
king size my pillow is only five
dollars more if you don't have my pillow
or you know someone who doesn't now is a
great time because for a limited time
mike lindell the inventor of my pillow
is offering
his premium my pillows for that
extraordinarily low price these things
are really comfortable
folks now is the time to buy not only
are you getting the lowest price ever
they're
an incredible christmas gift i mean as a
parent i can tell you i lack sleep
so do all of my friends this is a great
gift for somebody who lacks sleep
29.98 for a queen size premium my pillow
by now
mike lindell will extend his 60-day
money back guarantee to march 1st
20 21 go to mypillow.com click on that
radio listener square
there you will find not only this
amazing offer but also deep discounts on
all my pillow products including the
giza dream
bed sheets the mypillow mattress stopper
and my pillow towel sets or
call 800-651-1148 use promo code
dailywire again that's 800-651-1148
use promo code dailywire in just a
second we'll get to attorney general
william barr
stepping down and we'll get to
democratic infighting and again the
media narrative which the joe biden is
just too good for this world he's just
too good
he's just too wonderful a man for this
this particular world we'll get to that
in a second first
on monday december 21st the historical
docu-series apollo 11 what we saw
will be available exclusively at
dailywire.com it was originally released
as an audio podcast for apple and
spotify
what we saw will be available to watch
as well as listen to on the daily wire
apple tv or roku app or at dailywire.com
the docu-series takes a detailed look at
the apollo 11 mission to land a man on
the moon
the culmination of a heated decades-long
space race between cold war rivals
the us and the soviet union the podcast
explores one of america's greatest
accomplishments
through the eyes of the millions of
americans who lived through it it's an
incredible story
and you get to see it in real color i
mean it's great
apollo 11 what we saw a fantastic series
to watch with your loved ones
over the holiday break especially as we
are launching into a new space era right
now
get it for 20 off with code watch when
you become an insider or above member at
dailywire.com
subscribe make sure to
content you're download to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so meanwhile william barr the
attorney general has stepped down out of
his job
overall william bart did an excellent
job as attorney general despite the
massive slings and arrows it's amazing
to see how the media continued to treat
william barr despite the fact that
according to their lights
he should be a hero today i mean william
barr did not actually reveal news
of the hunter biden investigation i
think that that was a dicey move
considering that it was
overtly known i mean people were
actively reporting that he was under
investigation hunter biden the doj
refused to confirm or deny based on
justice department protocol that you
don't do anything that affects an
election
it turns out that refusing to comment on
a widely known matter is in fact
affecting an election i think there are
open questions to be asked about that i
do wonder
whether trump's requirement
his sort of bizarre requirement to
constantly go online and sound off about
these things pushed bar into a bad
position he kept saying over and over i
want william barr to prosecute hunter
biden i want william barr to open an
investigation into william
into hunter biden and and bar's like i'm
the head of the doj i'm supposed to be
impartial here how does it look if i
just announced that i'm in
i'm opening an investigation or it's
already open into biden
after you said to do that right that is
not exactly a great look
so i'm wondering if that had some impact
here in any case overall
william barr was a very strong attorney
general as laura ingram said on her show
last night people who are suggesting
that bayer is a weak attorney general
either on the left or on the right are
being absolutely inaccurate his
treatment of the mueller probe was
exemplary his his decisions whether or
not to prosecute in various cases
have been nearly invariably good okay so
william barr put in his resignation
yesterday
he said he would resign it next week
according to cnn his departure was
announced by the president on twitter
moments after accounting
and the electoral college put biden over
the 270 votes
he uh he tweeted out just had a very
nice meeting with attorney general bill
barr at the white house our relationship
has been a very good one he has done an
outstanding job
as per letter bill will be leaving just
before christmas to spend the holidays
with his family deputy attorney general
jeff rosen now a standing person will
become an acting attorney general highly
respected
richard donahue will be taking over
duties of deputy attorney general thank
you
to all there are some people who have
been suggesting the maybe who's going to
fire william barr but
it was it was basically irrelevant at
this point anyway a white house official
said barr was not forced out or fired
he said he wasn't asked to resign it was
very amicable amicable meeting another
person familiar with the matter
described the meeting
as cordial so barr put put out a letter
talking about this
he said that any outstanding allegations
of voter fraud would be content would
continue to be
reviewed he had said earlier this month
there was no widespread evidence of
voter fraud that had been brought to his
attention that doesn't mean no voter
fraud
and bar wrote a very complimentary
letter for trump he said your record is
all the more historic because you
accomplished it in the face of
relentless implacable resistance no
tactic no matter how abusive or
deceitful was out of bounds the nader of
this campaign was the effort to
if not ouster administration with
frenzies and baseless accusations
of collusion with russia so
barr is uh is moving out of the job of
course these are the the last days
anyway
for the for the bar doj no matter how
you were going to slice
it meanwhile as all of this goes on the
media are finally starting to notice
that
maybe there's some conflicts of interest
with joe and hunter by now it's fair to
talk about all of this
so michael sharer has a piece over the
washington post the last time joe biden
worked in the white house his son-in-law
howard crine
mentioned executives from his healthcare
startup from would be visiting
washington
the vice president promptly arranged a
meeting between the group which included
crime's brother stephen and president
barack obama in the oval office
he knew about startup health and was a
big fan of it howard crime the husband
of biden's daughter ashley
told the philadelphia business journal
in 2015. he asked for steve's number and
said i have to get him up here to talk
with barack
now biden is preparing to step back into
the oval office with radically different
expectations
about how he will handle the
relationship between his official power
and his family's private interest notice
how washington posted suddenly reporting
on this
until five seconds ago it was completely
verboten to talk about the fact
that joe has been facilitating his
family's business interests for years
it's perfectly obvious this has been
happening he's giving his son hunter
lifts
on air force two to china he was looking
the other way when hunter was going and
cashing checks in ukraine using his name
i mean it is it is perfectly obvious
what was going on for years but we were
told we were not allowed to report on
this now the washington post has decided
to report on it but how are they going
to report on it
not by suggesting that perhaps joe
biden's history
of familial corruption is bad but by
suggesting well you know now he's going
to change
it's a brand new time it's a new leaf
turn it over again the narrative
above all narrative narrative uber alice
my son my family will not be involved in
any business
any enterprising conflict with or
appears to be in conflict
the president-elect told cnn this month
according to the washington post that
pledge has now been handed over to
lawyers for the presidential
transition who are drafting new rules
for the biden white house that are
likely to be more restrictive than the
rules that govern the obama
administration
the potential family conflict both with
biden and its top white house advisors
are more extensive than the obama white
house confronted
bidenstein hunter is facing a federal
investigation over taxes paid on a
business venture in china which also
included biden's brother james
a situation that is certain to test the
president-elect's promise to let the doj
operate independently of his personal
interests
both men have worked for years at the
intersection of government and the
private sector using the biden name to
win work and sometimes partnering with
biden donors
through his lawyer hunter has promised
not to work for any more foreign
companies and to
keep his father personally uninvolved in
his business affairs
john owens the husband of biden's
sister's valerie and a former college
classmate of the president-elect
owns a delaware-based telemedicine
company that markets itself as a
solution amid pandemic restrictions with
medical second opinion operations in
europe and asia
the president-elect spoke to a
conference for the company metaguide
international in 2017 and the firm
boasted about it in its marketing
materials
biden and his wife joe have also dr joel
i mean come on hey hey
washington post is dr jill biden and his
wife
jill have also given speeches during the
trump administration at events produced
by startup health
a firm that has investments overseas and
that continues to boast about its biden
ties
and a 2011 oval office meeting with
obama among the investors is joe kiani
a major biden donor who has also had
biden speak at a patient safety
conference he sponsored in 2017.
much is riding on exactly how biden
decides to create the bright line he's
promised
existing ethics rules regulate the
disclosure of non-public government
intervention information
and financial conflicts for spouses and
minor children but the business dealings
of extended family
for both elected officials and political
appointees traditionally fall into a
legal and political
gray zone why look at that that's that's
amazing right now
really the question is how joe biden's
going to be you know going forward it's
not going to be about his history his
long-standing history of corruption
it's going to be about how things are
going forward wow the me
excellent job by the media it's safe to
do it now it's december 15th you're
allowed to report it now so i'm glad
that you're on it
also in the most complimentary fashion
which is that certainly joe biden
will not be a fox guarding the hen house
he will be just the greatest
the greatest guard against his own
corruption given his career
of not guarding against his own
corruption for sure that that's gonna be
it
well william barr is in fact leaving a
bit of a welcome gift for joe biden
according to the dailywire.com ryan
savage reporting special counsel john
durham is reportedly ramping up his
criminal investigation into the origins
of the fbi's counterintelligence
investigation into the 2016 campaign
durham u.s attorney recently tapped by
a.g barton special counsel
is apparently adding more prosecutors to
his team the latest development in the
case comes
after politico reported over the weekend
that durham has been zeroing in
on christopher steele politico reported
in a previously unreported move
durham enlisted a british law firm over
the summer to take steel to court in
london
aiming to compel him to turn over notes
he had taken of his meetings with the
fbi in 2016
according to people with direct
knowledge of the episode the underlying
context for the request people said
is that durham believes that steel's
notes could contain evidence
that fbi agents improperly disclosed
classified information about crossfire
hurricane as the bureau dubbed its
russia probe
in the course of questioning steele
about his own findings dna john
radcliffe said last week he thinks
durham should release an interim report
because some democrats had tried to
stop the investigation durham however is
appointed
special counsel that means it is very
difficult to get rid of him so
that's something that biden would
presumably have to contend with
meanwhile in other democratic news nancy
pelosi is desperate to retain her
speaker position
according to the daily wire emily zanati
reporting
speaker of the house pelosi is
desperately whipping support to maintain
her hold
on the speaker's position she's urging
her supporters in congress to return to
washington d.c in january
to be present for the vote even if
they're currently staying away over
covet 19
worries according to kevin mccarthy
nancy pelosi is fine with house
democrats skipping work if the votes are
about legislation
but in january she's going to demand
every democrat show up in person to vote
for her for speaker
her message is clear her power is more
important than anything else and she has
been in fact
demanding that her supporters return for
the vote
she is deeply worried that might there
might be some sort of challenge
she has had help from her top deputies
house majority leader steiny hoyer and
jim clyburn in south carolina according
to politico
she and her supporters have also
deployed some former obama
administration alum and big donors to
help squeeze undecided democrats
according to emily zanati pelosi is
currently leading the race only by a
narrow margin
her wit her rift with progressives and
democratic socialists in congress has
only grown wider
democrats had a number of unexpected
losses in the november election
that means that they now hold just a
10-seat margin over republicans 222 to
212.
there's one last race that is
outstanding it is likely that that will
turn to the republicans
as well so hilariously enough the person
who's coming into the crosshairs now is
aoc
the r i'm sorry not aoc the honorable
representative alexandra ocasio-cortez
d-twitch
she's coming into the crosshairs now
because she has suggested that she's
going to support
nancy pelosi she had to tweet out they
aren't demanding anything as an
assumption and a false one
these structural negotiations happen
they just aren't live-tweeted these
negotiations started months ago and
include house rules
paygo exemptions committee makeup vote
commitments investigations et cetera so
her answer is that she's holding nancy
pelosi that are she's holding her feet
to the fire
yeah sure sure you are alexandra i'm
sure that's exactly what is happening
good stuff alrighty in just a second
we're going to be getting to more
bizarre
moves by the radical left so the ongoing
battle
inside the democratic party between the
radical left
and the and the moderate left it really
is largely just a question of timing
because let's face it joe biden is not
significantly more moderate than the
radical leftists in his coalition he
just wants to get them more slowly
and the media are trying to cover for
him you wanna you wanna see an
obvious ridiculous example of media bias
michelle borstein has a piece over at
the washington post suggesting that joe
biden is gonna change what it means to
be catholic
okay i have a feeling that no that
institution a couple thousand years old
i don't think the doddering octogenarian
who can barely get a sentence out of his
face
is going to be changing the meaning of
catholicism for millions of people i
just don't think that's going to happen
here's the washington post however biden
could redefine what it means to be a
catholic in good standing
catholics are divided on whether that is
good he's not going to be dividing
people
on what it means to be a catholic in
good standing okay
it's not going to suddenly become
catholic church doctrine that same-sex
marriage is wonderful and abortion is
fine
both of which are things that joe biden
apparently believes
according to the washington post however
again this is in their religion section
it's not not bad
catholics view on biden seem to serve as
a proxy for what kinds of catholicism
they think most urgently needs to be
advanced
should it be more focused on qualities
like engagement and empathy or on
purifying doctrine
is it as interested in catholic
teachings on poverty refugees and in the
environment
as those on sexuality and reproduction
or should it continue to place abortion
law above all
see here's the thing uh you shouldn't
have to have those values in competition
with one another this is something that
catholics know
all religious people know this okay a a
religious worldview is holistic
it encompasses things ranging from views
on poverty to things like abortion it's
not like you have to pick one or choose
the other
but according to the washington post you
do you see and joe biden stands
with catholicism on issues like poverty
and the environment
but you know he's just a little wishy
washy on the whole killing babies that
are in the womb
and also same-sex marriage like that's
he's not great on catholic doctrine but
you know
you're gonna have to choose despite
these divisions as the washington post
biden is poised to make his mark on
american catholicism for the next four
years the country will see its president
go to mass every sunday take out a
rosary at times of contemplation and
quote his favorite childhood nuns in
catholic poets
it will watch him try to navigate
polarizing issues of special interest to
his church that john f kennedy never had
to take a position on
abortion lgbtq rights and climate change
among them
okay i i have just a quick point here um
no that is my point my point is no i i
know many many many
many believing catholics like people who
are deep believers who go to mass on a
regular basis
not one of them looks to joe biden as a
catholic leader not one
okay he he is a political leader who
happens to identify as catholic although
he's been refused communion in at least
a couple of churches because of his
position on abortion
i'm frankly in a state of bewilderment
it's how he has not been refused
communion everywhere given his position
on abortion
same-sex marriage and not only that but
because he's talked about the morality
of same-sex marriage not just his legal
status
but also his belief that a boy can
become a girl and a girl can become a
boy i mean these are completely
violative
of catholic doctrine now he's free to
take whatever position he wants
but i just find it weird that the
washington post is trying to turn him
into a catholic leader
what the washington post is really
saying is that catholicism would be
great except for all the catholicism
involved
and religion is great except for when it
comes to doctrine
jade hendricks former executive director
of government relations at the us
conference of catholic bishops said
most people don't pay attention to
bishops they do to the u.s president
when the president is almost
diametrically opposed to the most basic
human right that creates problems across
the board
how bishops address this is tricky but
if they don't president biden can
redefine the perception of what it is to
be a catholic in good standing yes i
mean it would be about time
for religious catholics to stand up and
say no we are not going to be paying
attention to joe biden's
commitment on issues like abortion
speaking of which just a couple of
logical correlators to joe biden's
political positions when it comes to
sort of the radicalism of the democratic
party
just want to point this out so joe biden
literally said in a town hall that
nine-year-olds should be able to decide
whether they're a boy or a girl
that not only does not jibe with
catholic doctrine
it does not drive with human reason or
biology so there was a tweet that came
up last night
and i i thought this was just a
fascinating tweet because it does show
the logical conclusion
like the logical endpoint of the lessons
the leftist position
on bio biological sex and gender so
there is a um
there is an orlando trans activist and
science writer
uh named zinnia z jump tv
okay and this tweet started to go viral
last night even though it was about
a week and a half old and here is what
the tweet says
if children can't consent to puberty
blockers which pause any permanent
changes
even with the relevant professional
evaluation how can they consent to the
permanent and irreversible changes that
come with their own puberty with no
professional evaluation
whatsoever this is literally a position
that permanent changes are fine as long
as you are not trans
an inability to offer informed consent
or understand the long-term consequences
is actually an argument for putting
every single cis and trans person on
puberty blockers
until they acquire that ability
okay that okay so that sounds wild to
you okay if you follow what
this person is saying this crazy person
this person is saying
that because sex is a sign of birth
right there's language that the left now
uses on a routine basis sex is a sign of
birth
when you have a baby you actually can't
tell the gender this is something
charles blow said
on twitter the other day and i laughed
at him for it he suggested that if a
baby comes out of the womb you look at
the baby the baby's girl
you can't actually say that that baby is
a girl because the baby may turn out to
be a boy
you can't have a gender reveal party
based on an ultrasound because
gender is chosen later okay so this
trans activist is saying okay if that's
the case
if gender is chosen later then shouldn't
we put every kid on puberty blockers so
they are not
forced by their hormones into the
uncomfortable position of being at odds
with their chosen gender
why not make kids genderless widgets
from the time that they are small so
that their hormones don't force them
into the binary decision between being a
boy and being a girl
that is what this trans activist is
saying now that sounds crazy because it
is crazy
but it is totally the logical conclusion
of the position that gender is chosen
and that sex is assigned at birth
because if you see human beings as
genderless widgets
and sex as a biological nuisance then
this is the logical position this is the
logical endpoint now nobody on the left
ever talks about the logical endpoint
because
they don't want to talk about the
logical endpoint the moment you start
talking about logical endpoints for
these positions
the entire position completely falls
apart but this person happens to be
hitting the nail on the head
if you believe that children choose
their own choose their own adventure
then presumably you should put every
seven-year-old in america on puberty
blockers so they have the freedom to
choose
whether they are boys or girls this
should be the position okay another
radical position
that i noticed and i think that is
worthy of know noah burlesque is a
person who writes for nbc news he writes
think pieces for nbc news
he tweeted out the other day quote
parents are tyrants
parent is an oppressive class like rich
people or white people
a lot to unpack right there so note noah
burlesky is i believe a white writer for
nbc news who apparently is not earning a
low salary
i don't know if he has kids if he does
what could he's 50 years old
guys i assume he like at a certain point
your parental issues are going to have
to be solved
but parents are tyrants parents is an
oppressive class like rich people or
white people
well once you take the position that the
government knows better than you do how
to raise your own child
that the american federation of teachers
should decide exactly what your child
learns
and that whatever is the prevailing
leftist ideology of the day ought to be
crammed down on parents parents really
don't have
autonomy to decide what their kids
should and should not learn in fact
parents shouldn't even have autonomy to
decide
what public school to send their kids to
well the idea there is that you are you
are in fact liberating children from
their parents this is a
sort of marxist trope in the communist
manifesto there is this idea that
parents are in fact an oppressive class
and that you need the state to liberate
children from the bondage
of their parents now in the real world
here's how we see all of this
there is accepted tradition brought down
over thousands of years of human history
human nature is fundamentally unchanging
parents
are there to provide the established
wisdom to their children
over time people can determine that
perhaps an established piece of wisdom
is false but that requires careful
consideration
parents are not an oppressive class
parents are will liberate you from the
shackles
of barbarity if you've ever met a child
you understand that kids
cannot be trusted to do anything parents
need to be there
not only to provide for them but to
guide them in the confusing process of
growing up
but if you're a big believer in the idea
that parents are
oppressors that children are innately
wonderful and not only innocent but good
and that is only the shackles of society
that make them bad these are the
position positions you end up with the
state should liberate children from
their parents
the state should allow children to
decide what their gender is
now if all this sounds crazy it's
because it is crazy it is crazy
but you watch anything that is crazy
becomes mainstreamed within five years
within five years this all will be part
of the mainstream discussion
will be when should puberty i mean the
puberty blocker conversation about
whether kids should be
should be having puberty blockers
whether or not they are trans
that stuff is basically already on the
table i mean when we are talking about
judges mandating that parents be who
don't want their kids to have fury
blockers give their kids puberty
blockers at the age of 10 because one
parent disagrees with the other parent
or when a kid declares themselves trans
at 12 and a judge decides
that if a parent refuses to do that then
the kid needs to be taken out of the
home this is already happening in some
areas of canada for example
that is the case that is being made now
how does any of that
all of that gender ideology all that
belief about
the evils of parenting and the good of
the state all of that
is buried deep within the sort of
moderate veneer of joe biden's
philosophy
he just doesn't want to get at it or he
doesn't want to think about it because
he might come to these sorts of
conclusions eventually
the hard left will come to those
conclusions if they think about it long
enough
so what i would like to know in the end
is how any of that drives with things
like catholic doctrine
or history or for that matter decency
how do these things become mainstream
they become mainstreamed when the media
decide that it's time to silence you
about these particular issues now it's
gonna take a while on this i mean this
is the bleeding edge of the radical left
let's not pretend this is the
mainstream democratic party position it
is not the mainstream democratic party
position
is that boys can become girls and girls
can become boys not that we have to
mandate puberty blockers for children
but that
children should be able to get puberty
blockers if they declare themselves a
member of the opposite sex
but it's not that far a move from one to
the other
and it is not the position of the
democratic party that parents are an
oppressive class it is just the position
of the democratic party
that if child protective services
decides that you are raising your child
not in a not in accordance with the
proper woke ideology
that you're a bad parent and they they
should show up to try and re-educate
your children right
so again all of this is the sort of
exaggerated form
of the moderated argument but it's
important to recognize the exaggerated
form of moderate argument because it
does shed light on what the moderated
argument actually is
in so many of these cases you're seeing
that
you're seeing exactly this relationship
between radicalism and moderation inside
the actual formal democratic party these
days
you're seeing this battle break out
between the ilhan omars of the world and
the joe bidens of the world ilhan omar
for example
she said yesterday that she's angry that
the radicals don't have a big enough
seat at the biden table
don't worry they'll get the big enough
seat they will eventually
may take a couple of years but you watch
senator bernie sanders says that he
doesn't think the progressive movement
has a big enough seat at the table with
the biden team do you agree with him
i do uh and this is you know what we
have been
saying and asking for we
worked diligently in in trying to make
sure that the people
understood that it was important for us
to get rid of
uh trump but to have someone who was
going to be partner with us in in
governing
for progress in our country and we
continue to be hopeful
in having that partnership okay so you
watch the radicals are on the march how
do we know by the way that the radicals
are on the march because
ilhan omar and rashida talib and linda
sarsour are all campaigning for raphael
warnock you know who else is campaigning
for rafael warnock down in georgia
joe biden he's campaigning for a guy
who's openly anti-semitic down in
georgia and who hangs out with the likes
of linda sarsour
by the way raphael warnock new piece of
footage of him yesterday
the senate candidate in georgia uh he uh
praised louis veracon's nation of islam
as important
which is interesting because louis
farrakhan has suggested uh that jews
need to
to experience a little bit of that
genocide kind of stuff here is uh here's
raphael warnock
in 2013 okay this is not when he was a
kid when in 2013 praising the nation of
islam
the nation of islam is significant
but its numbers don't come anywhere near
the membership of our churches
it's its voice has been important and
its voice has been important even for
the development of black theology
because it was the black muslims who who
challenged black preachers
good stuff there from raphael warnock
this is the person the democrats
are trying to put into the united states
senate other democrats who have gained
prominence during the
this moderate era in in democrat
thinking
ted wheeler so ted wheeler that mayor of
portland um
he um he actually apologized i'm not
kidding he apologized
for dismantling the autonomous zone in
portland so they tried to create a chas
chop in portland and ted wheeler
sent in the uh sent in the troops
basically and said
nope you're not doing that well now
apparently he has apologized
and they are negotiating with the
occupiers it's hilarious
this is all according to red house on
mississippi that is the uh that is the
protest group the daily wire reported
last week that wheeler ordered members
of the red house autonomous zone
to leave our face eviction by force
after protesters who'd been occupying
the land around red house for several
weeks
set up makeshift barriers and declared
the space indigenous land
wheeler announced that portland police
would use all lawful means to clear
protesters from that home according to
oregon
public broadcasting at the time wheeler
went so far to say as to that
that he would end the illegal occupation
however red house now says the mayor has
apologized for the incident and is in
negotiations with both the protesters
and the home's owners and protesters
reportedly agreed to remove barriers
surrounding the autonomous zone
wheeler then confirmed the negotiation
and a subsequent deal he said this
agreement is an important step toward
de-escalation
and a long-term resolution for the
neighborhood and the kinney family i
maintain the measured optimism we can
accomplish this step
and move toward the next steps to
advance the safety and well-being of the
family and safety of the neighborhood
yeah ted wheeler standing strong for
moderation over in
portland and the moderates in the
democratic party the only question is
when they will cave not if they will
cave because
if we've seen one thing among democrats
they never move back to the center for
very long
it is always a stop gap holding move
until they move radically to the left so
watch for that to happen in the near
future cheered on of course
by the members of the mainstream media
alrighty join us later for two
additional hours of the ben shapiro show
or while you wait check out the michael
knowles show on dailywire.com right now
he'll be discussing president trump's
final pathway to victory i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's high events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crand
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2020.
the electoral college votes for biden
leaving president trump just one
route left to win michigan orders a
forensic audit of voting machines and
a hollywood actress calls for gay
inmates to violate the president of the
united states
check it out on the michael knowles show